[Music]
remember the rapper Kelly yeah did I
tell you what happened when I like yeah
you went to yeah yeah okay what was it
like a Rams game or something no it was
wrong yeah yeah the thing was his team
reached out and was like we want you to
meet him or something like it was like a
thing I was supposed to go there and we
were supposed to like I don't know like
take a picture together or something
like that but it just didn't even get
close to happening you're like yo Kelly
this is Cody he's like
oh just like didn't and I was like oh
damn in September or something he DMS me
was like yo like my girl and I watched
all your videos like when's the next
button video and I was like oh and then
you could see above that I had tagged
them in 2019 because that was when it
was like a it was like footage of his
show after right after he like you know
it was a pretty [__] move yeah
I wonder if he has any idea probably not
no probably not he's runs wrong but
anyways yeah Wally's friends with him
too I guess or they didn't they know
each other or something I don't know
[Laughter]
what's up Kelly
yo what's going on my boys what's going
on Killy hey thanks for thanks for
calling in why are you doing your like
radio you can hear me yeah I can hear
you
hello Lee how are you guys what's going
on we're good we're good I appreciate
you I appreciate you calling it damn I
can't believe Kelly called into our
podcast just to talk to Walid
long time no see man have you been bro
last time I seen you Wali we were turned
up I know it's so long ago that's crazy
yeah man you remember that right yeah I
remember that man why you got your bit
voice on what is this a bit no it's not
a bit I'm just catching up with my
friends don't you dab this [__] voice
that you use yo kill me you know Noel
and Zach right yeah of course of course
of course what's going on what up bro yo
Kelly what's up man I don't know I don't
know if you remember what we met
yo that's crazy I I don't remember his
name but
but uh nice to meet you
[Laughter]
but yo well I heard you were I heard you
were DJing bro we gotta lock in now I'm
gonna send you a track yeah yeah are you
talking about Noel are you talking yeah
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you know it's just that Toronto
connection we have we gotta you know we
gotta turn up man yeah we got to put on
for the city I'm gonna send you a track
we're gonna close this man yeah no I'm
ready I'm ready yeah man me too yeah me
too yeah now you're from Calgary be
quiet okay
well yeah look what's going on like how
are you guys we're good man good man
meanwhile leader just chilling here yeah
hanging out with Zach calling it today
yeah like yeah Wally since last time I
seen you when was that like five years
ago five years ago we're going crazy
back then yo real [__] that was a crazy
that was the best time I ever had in my
entire life
you guys went crazy yo yeah yeah I know
Zach I seen you've been running I need
to get like you again yeah you need to
get like you bro yeah dude uh I'm up to
seven miles now so anytime you want to
run again I'll go up to Toronto yeah we
have to link up bro cause you have to
come here
I'm on my fitness journey I'm trying to
get like you gang thanks hell yeah [__]
yeah all right we'll kill you man thanks
for calling in bro
yes nice to see you man
good catch up man
dude that's my [__] dog right there
bro [__] he was supposed to call in foul
tip not this I'm sorry guys
no it's not available
[Laughter]
oh my God it's killing me
hey but what's up it's Wally
you definitely did a ramp up your voice
I feel like a sitcom for a second you
know what celebrities come on oh
hip-hop art is killing you
what are you doing here
damn that was some sitcom [__] right
there
what was more Awkward the Jared off
situation or this situation
well the Jared goth thing wasn't a bit
Yeah Yeah but like it was just awkward
and after he hung out realizing like you
actually have never really or remember
that you did link up a little yes I
don't know what you're asking me but
yeah just just not your head he'll stop
talking
so this was very awkward for you you
know what's no no that was I knew that
was you planned that no it's poison
[__] excuse me
you were doing your bit voice
this is my regular voice no it's not
sorry if I have an accident am I just
being racist
um he DMS me after we talked about it
and jaegan yeah yeah well I told them to
so
yeah that's the voice what lead makes
before he's [__] yeah yeah yeah oh I'm
so excited oh I have to do foreplays I'm
excited dude when Dad came on eight ball
and was doing his impression of me I was
gonna kick his ass
I like was actually offended no you did
oh yeah was it him yeah you also did one
yeah yeah well Ben said you're the only
one who laughs like good
good
and I said you always talk like like
you're in trouble or something like oh
I don't know
I can do an impression of you yeah just
to shave some nice
yeah I'll do the pressure of you no I
don't want to hear it
no I'm good I don't want to hear it you
can start shaving the top of his
hairline aggressively
who am I it's just who am I waiting
downstairs
I'm Cody
oh dude you go home you walk in the door
and while leeches with Kelsey on the
couch like what the [__]
impression of you
like ew babe who's this Stranger in our
house what no Kelsey it's me did your
parents walk in get this man out of here
no ring on my finger while he's like
what's wrong looking for your ring your
dad has a gun he's trying to figure out
and then while he's like no Dad it's me
good
he's like that is my son
get this stranger out of my [__]
house
today it's your day
it's your episode you guys gotta hear uh
Zach's wakandan accent whoa
[Laughter]
yeah exactly yeah
I really don't I never even watched the
movie oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
good to see you
[Music]
the whole time we were at Chili's you
were doing it
[Laughter]
that really is such a good embarrassing
bit dude just to a stranger at a bar my
guy does the best man well no you know
who did that to me my girl we're at like
a social setting she's like you guys got
in here you're like what the [__]
voice goes higher
yeah
Zach what the [__] was that God damn it
I did it so happen it's just like
checking the titles
yeah no keep going keep going I'm over
here
no uh did you watch the movie no I
haven't watched a movie
I watched Puss in Boots
I have a good Puss in Boots
and Boots that's racist
that was all good
why didn't you stick with your recorder
thing bro
do it again
it's pulling us in Boots what what
nationality is that yeah
hahaha
[Laughter]